my name is Aaron harvat today I will
show you a few tricks coding tricks with
the
that are using the latest c-sharp syntax
switch
means c-sharp version 7 8 9 10. the uh
if you followed the new pieces of syntax
you must have noticed that there is a
steady stream of functional syntactical
construct in c-sharp that are being
added and improved version to version so
now we have a very powerful language in
which we can freely mix paradigms and
that is what I will show you today not
not exactly the syntax but the Mind
process the
designing and coding process that is
mixing functional modeling with object
oriented modeling with the a touch of
procedural when needed so that you can
write
code quickly and make powerful and
flexible designs that is what what new
c-sharp additions are letting us do
you can download source code there will
be
a bit of source codes to to read if you
like this is the address
and
while it take a photo of this code
these are all the slides I I prepared
for you sorry for this everything else
will be called
foreign
I will be demonstrating
designing with C sharp and if you want
to show off a language feature or a
bunch of them what you normally do is is
not to take a business application
because everybody would fall asleep by
the end of this demo and half of the
demo would take introducing you to
whatever business I I had in mind for
demonstration purposes when you want to
show the language the best way to do
that is I found is to is to use a
board game
any board game because everybody
understand them and the trick with this
approach is that if you ever wanted to
uh to program a board game you would not
do it the way I will show you here
but anyway that will show you the power
of C sharp
features that we have today
this is the
view component of a
Blazer webassembly application you don't
need to to know any of those but it
would probably amuse you to see what
they can do in only a few lines of code
if you haven't had the opportunity to
work with them anyway uh what you saw in
this board are UI elements that will
need to have a
backing model these axes and O's and you
will see these two bluish
cells that can be clicked they shouldn't
be a here present but I have added them
for you to see so that is the third
element and we have a line we have four
elements that need to be modeled in the
backing code
so
this is the home and the way cell
component
we will need the row and column where to
draw them
then the winning line where to draw from
and two four parameters and those blue
cells that are clickable they have a
Lambda what to do when somebody clicks
them
so we need a backing model which does
all this I have just removed those
clickable cells because the game is over
and nothing should be clicked
we need something that will generate UI
code like this
and then how do we do that
this is the backing model the board that
will do all this
and allow us to play the game
and this is the UI
backing code this is effectively The
View model
which will hold a reference to the board
model and do things to that display it
that is where webassembly will take over
and simply display all the changes we
make to the board
on the screen but we also need commands
to restart the game and to make a move
so how do we implement this backing
model
the Crux of this presentation will be on
designing on a designing method which is
trying to quickly prototype
a domain model
you need
a quick prototype to see that everything
works that everything you had in mind
can be done that it can be tied to that
view model seen on the screen
and
when I do quick prototyping and I do it
all the time
I constantly use
tuples
which have been around for
quite a few years already
you can
organize your data into tuples So to
avoid into introducing new classes
one problem we have you know strongly
typed languages is proliferation of
classes in a normal project we would
have thousands of classes and on every
1000 classes maybe 800 of them will be
this large
and when you start designing a model you
you don't want to design I don't know
five or ten classes just to show those
four elements on the screen use tuples
and draw them
here in the view model or in the view
that is
look what I can do
I can
iterate
through variable variables of type Tuple
home and then reference
home.rowhome.com do you know how it is
row and call symbols are resolved
when you assign a variable or return a
value that is a tuple
Tuple is
very
close to
a read-only array
it has it is implementing i2uple
interface which is only giving you the
indexer and the count nothing more and
the the information about names is lost
in the process
so how does the compiler know component
names later it knows no those through
metadata whenever you assign a variable
or return a value that is Tuple metadata
remember the names of its components
and so you can refer back to them
but you don't have to assign any
variable
you can use what is called Tuple
deconstruction you can assign
a tuple
into something that looks like a tuple
but it's effectively two variables two
separate variables that have been uh
declared and assigned in this line so in
the line below you don't need anything
from dot anything you know you just have
two variables low and calm and
if you want to spare yourself some
three four four
letters you can use their keyword in
front of the Tuple and again both
variables will be declared and set in
every iteration
then
this is not where
the construction into tuple's ends
anything that can be deconstructed into
a tuple can be used as a source
for multiple variables that you can
assign then and we will meet the
constructors in in just a minute
also notice what I told you
I have named components row and call
here and row and column here those two
are separate so you can assign to
whatever you need over there and produce
whatever you can over here and those two
things will work very well
okay I'll do the same for away moves
add a
a loop and then
by the way I have started
uh dot net watch run so that whenever I
save
code this page will refresh
which didn't happen yet
or I missed something maybe I missed it
so whatever we add to code will uh in
only a few seconds show up in in the
browser as well so
the next thing is this look at this
I will have to de-zoom a little
can you see this code
this is very important part
multi-level Tuple deconstruction
you can deconstruct a tuple of tuples
if that's what you like
and it will work
because any component can also be a
tuple recursively and the result of
assigning
this Tuple of tuples is the appearance
of four independent variables that I can
use inside the loop
and
back here
I will have to the zoom again
now look at this terrible terrible
signature
an eye innumerable of tuples of tuples
now this is the result of quick
prototyping
uh when you start using tuples and Funk
delegates to write let's say
for the first time this is the
functional piece of code to write
functional code
ugliness will sneak in very quickly your
code will start to inflate in signatures
and all that for the sake of
shrinking on a number of classes so you
have to think which one of those goals
is is more important to you
in the quick prototyping phase I
normally
sustain this I say all right I will
survive this 80 characters of a
declaration of a single variable I'll
survive that but later
I will surely add a class which wraps
these four variables in into an object
so to reduce the size of this signature
anyway
uh
this will work
if you observed there was a compile time
error at the end of this line but now
it's gone
everything compiles fine which means
that the multi-level deconstruction of
tuples works well and compiler knows
very well what I meant with this code
Plus
playable cells
there will be none there will be an
empty sequence of those so right now
we have
a complete
here is the UI which is simply drawing
those clickable cells tying them with
that Lambda that makes a move we have an
entire query model
in only 20 lines of code I've I have
covered all the queries
for the UI
without defining any class except the
the core model class
we can add
commands now and already as I said it
there is a clear separation between uh
queries and commands in this model
if you want to
design functional models which are
quick to design and they will save you a
lot of troubles later
then you will probably wish to separate
queries which turn out to be just
Expressions that calculate the result
from from the backing state from
commands which will in fact return a new
instance of the model so right now we
are
all the way into into functional design
how many of you are
acquainted with the functional design
one two and a half
two and a half well uh what I'm trying
to show you here is how how easy it is
to design a class which is separating
Expressions that return values from the
backing state so that nobody knows what
that backing state is and currently I
don't even have a backend state from
commands that you are issuing and all
those commands must correspond to some
action that triggers them like there are
buttons on the screen to play on this or
on that position or to restart the game
or to initially load it this is the
initial loading of the game there will
be uh
restart of the game and making the move
those are the actions that we do on our
on our Board model so here I will just
expose a static initialize method which
is hiding away the construction which
currently has nothing to do and
these are the restart and make move
actions on the UI which must have
something that corresponds to them in
the model and functional design
is to make the board immutable and when
restarting
just create a new board
that is sufficient in this situation and
playing would also create a new board
right now I don't have any
implementation for playing the moves but
I will add them
in the prototyping phase I will say
whatever somebody clicked on the screen
let's do nothing just avoid throwing
exceptions and things like that and we
have an empty prototype
for a class which allows all queries and
all commands for the tic-tac-toe game
played on on the screen
these this is the view model it will
initialize using the static Constructor
it will restart the board by setting the
new
board in the UI so this is the view
model it is mutable
but the domain model is immutable
I may say I am at that disappointed that
there are so few of you who are using uh
functional modeling in the domain
I think at least that you should
investigate that and read a bit because
when applied to more complex
applications than this toy
they pay back
a lot they are making many typical
mistakes impossible
many typical bugs cannot even be made
and
I have
uh if I don't forget I will give you a
hint what can be done with a with an
immutable domain model in this toy demo
that
can be done with mutable uh
implementation of this same board but
with codes that is this large and
requires hours of debugging and it is
like three minutes of coding with
immutable uh domain model
making a move will delegate to the play
method that observe every method is
returning a new board object and UI is
the only mutable component here
so this completes
the entire prototype
if you watched me work on a business
application I would do the same thing
really
because it is so simple
and it lets me see the effects of my
actions on the screen
I have saved everything this should be
this is not refreshed what is this
yes the blue squares are
the blue squares are away because the
game is over they should not appear and
they are not appearing so my prototype
is currently working fine
and now comes the second phase where we
discover the new classes so that we can
enhance our
domain model
so the result is the immutable class
which is
using sequences in tuples which are 100
functional programming uh artifacts
everything I use here is functional and
still the whole application is object
oriented clearly because it's using the
object-oriented view model over there
that is consuming a functional domain
model from from this place
let's start introducing classes then
we see the drawing column always uh
operate together
how many of you have used record types
so far
two so from 2.5 we are down to two
record types are an excellent tool and
you will see instead of saying a class
you would say a record uh record is
implementing value typed equality for us
and it is implementing
properties for us
you will see that in just a minute
so instead of using a tuple you would
probably choose to use an object of a
class which at least carries strong
typing requirements so uh
tuples are have the same problem as Funk
delegates in C sharp and actions uh you
can assign them to anything that
corresponds to the same signature
which means that you can for example in
in this game you can make a terrible
mistake by assigning X Y coordinates to
row and column coordinates the problem
in that is that X and Y should be
switched you know and that is a bug if
you forget to do that and if you do
forget to do that compiler is not going
to see it for you
a tuple assignment and fund delegate
assignment and action uh delegate
assignment except anything that
satisfies the the signature
and we
already have a strongly typed language C
sharp which has a static code analysis
the best one that exists a compiler and
we should use that power
after the prototyping phase to introduce
strong names that is classes to Concepts
that will control assignment for us and
let us avoid bugs but now I have a
problem I cannot create a in this
prototype and still showing a
displaying a fixed content on this on
the screen but I cannot do that uh here
because I cannot assign tuples to cells
there's
another concept that can help us
how many of you
recognize distinction between
subclassing and subtyping
this is a trick question
foreign
and even if you implement an interface
they are
but look at this if you
for example Define an implicit or
explicit operator
then you can turn
you can turn a tuple
into an object of a class
and then what is
the subtyping relationship between
tuples and this class
if you can assign
a tuple
of two integers to sell it means the
Tuple of three integers is a subtype of
cell
right
subtyping is a set
relationship
when talking about types types will
Define a set of objects of that type
and then a subtype is a subset of that
set
so subtype are special objects that are
also uh part of that larger type
subclassing
is subtyping obviously
but subclassing is
more about
inheritance
and I like to say that subclassing is an
inheritance relationship and I'm not
sure that I invented that sentence
and subtyping is a set relationship
and I like to think in terms of types
because
I tend
to avoid inheritance
because when you inherit implementation
that's it that's what you get
it is much easier for you to use
behavior that you need as a component
and that is that old principle favor
object composition over class
inheritance
you can always
you can always pack a few components of
certain types and those types can
Implement certain interfaces so that you
can pick concrete classes which you will
use to to construct an object at the
runtime
with subclassing you cannot do that it
is fixed at compile time and you cannot
change the structure of of a class
so this was a long
uh piece of talk about types but
implicit operators are a typical
syntactic syntax that helps you
implement
subtyping
without subclassing
and you see this is compiling fine now
and please don't do this in your code
this is very dangerous
because now any Tuple of two integers is
assignable to sell
and it will silently convert to cell and
you might not be aware of that I have
seen a library
that that had to do with some networking
which
had an implicit conversion to string
which was not to string but an implicit
operator because they wanted to push
anything Through the Wire
and what happened
in one place was that somehow I cannot
now I cannot remember the exact code
what happened but somehow tostring was
invoked
and
the element which expected string coming
from an implicit operator which did the
whole bunch of
constructed
the entire message from an object now it
was just the name of the type
and the software uh broke down and they
they were looking for bug for about two
days
because nobody knew that tostring was
invoked and nobody even knew that there
is an implicit to string operator
so
be very careful about
feature like this I am using a feature
like this in testing
where as you can witness
it takes no time to construct a testing
set for example
but since you cannot Define
an operator in a piece of code which
does not belong to either of these two
types you cannot create a third type and
Define this implicit operator on that
one
I'm usually doing the same thing using
an extension method like to sell which
is applied to the Tuple
and then again
if you tried
functional programming with c-sharp if
you gave it a try you would see that
that many operations there are
implemented as extension methods that
are applied to a certain type
and that technique which I am
intensively using in testing but not in
in production code is again making my
code very readable very short and
effective so I can make a sequence of
tuples and then say just convert this to
cells and I have a test case
and now comes
the trick question why does this compile
over here
I have returned a sequence of cell
objects
and over there I'm consuming a sequence
of
integer integer tools
yes because cell here is a record
and so we come to the question what the
record type is
and why you should use it if I wanted to
use a class
they would immediately appear a couple
of compiled time errors
because for one thing I'm missing
properties
record is declaring public read-only
properties for us it is declaring a
public Constructor which accepts two
components and sets those the properties
in the order of appearance
then
the other thing
it implements I Equitable of cell
strongly typed I equal trouble you know
that it is good if you need equality
tests it is good to implement this
interface because it is uh
avoiding uh type check
the general
equals from a system.object is accepting
an object and then it must check its
type so it has a get hash code this is
fairly new hash code static class with
combine static method
how many of you have been using this in
practice
how many of you won so we are down to
one
and how many of you had the opportunity
to implement
to override getcash code
in practice
I suppose many yes at least half of you
so this is common and you know about
xoring about multiplying integers by 17
removing
overflow checks and things like that
forget that start using this
because
this this static method is doing that
better than any of us here can do in
most occasions they know what they're
doing I for example have no idea what
I'm doing when I create my own hash
functions
then what does the record do it
implements
General equals and it implements
strongly typed equals
in
C sharp 10
you can
create
record structs
in C sharp nine and eight uh only
reference types
records are supported
when you declare a record struck
you will get something that is almost
identical to a common struct because you
know the struct also has value type
equality implemented
but instructs it is implemented via
reflection which is slow
and if you declared the same thing as
records fact compiler would jump in and
generate specific members for you
which are as fast as one can get there's
no faster method than that
so this is what record means
except one thing if you notice
this
should not compile yes there is a
compile time error deconstruction into a
tuple does not work
you must Implement your own
deconstructor in your custom class which
is doing the opposite process from The
Constructor it uh
it sets output variables
and now you have it all the constructors
appeared a couple of years ago but I
actually never wrote a single
deconstructor ever
what I did
was to start records when they appeared
and then to use this
because record is looking like a tuple
but it has a name a class name so there
is no
room for questions did I assign the
right thing yes if it compiles yes
uh and it also has deconstruction
so that if I wanted to
use it in a functional style like in UI
I don't want to bother with classes or
anything and I just need drawing column
I can do that as well
simply said
okay this works now
all right
all this code
all this from line 5 to 33 that's some
27 8 lines of code no the two 31 25
lines of code is a word bracket
and that is the reason why you should
use records
yes
sorry
yes it is immutable you can make it
mutable if you want uh I also think it
has a
init settings so that you can initialize
uh once with curly brackets
but not change later so it is uh
immutable after Construction
so I can use the cell here
nope
all right
what about this
a tuple of topos
let's define a class which is the line
which has two components two cells line
from and two cell
and you will see that line is also
declared as a record
as well it has two components
therefore it is decomposable into
a tuple of tuples here
it is recursively decomposable
deconstructable not decomposable
but then we have a problem in this
design
cells
are not really constrained except that I
forgot to check bounce
but we can do that
lines have a more strict constraint if
you look at the
board you cannot draw a line which goes
from the
bottom left corner to the middle cell
that line is is invalid so
this is the example where we have
where what record or what what a
compiler generates for us is not what we
need
we need a custom Constructor
even better I have a better idea we we
might introduce static Factory functions
and hide the Constructor away
so that nobody can just generate a line
no tell us what row column diagonal
anti-diagonal there are four kinds of
them so we need effectively four
distinct Constructors
what do you do with the record
you are free to implement anything you
want from those standard elements of a
class and still call it a record you see
it is still a record
compiler will notice your members and
just don't do anything about those
however what I did here is to implement
a private Constructor and public
deconstructor so you can always read but
you cannot write whatever you like in
here
please observe that there are no
exceptions anywhere here I'm plugging
all the holes for invalid objects except
testing boundaries
and I'm creating
a functional design
which is uh
which leaves no room for a Target I have
no other way to tell you this
if you create this if you create classes
in this style there will be no place to
plant a duck
I had a colleague in in the office who
came one day said that his daughter
asked him what he was doing so late at
work and he said I was I was removing
bugs from code and she said why did you
put bugs there
so that's the point functional design is
reducing bug count at least in my
case from my experience by an order of
magnitude
so back to records I had to implement
deconstructor because once I took over
the Constructor compiler moves away and
says okay your job
I don't know what
properties you mean to expose
I have exposed properties I have
initialized them in the Constructor so
it's also my job to expose a
deconstructor
however
equality members and I Equitable offline
and everything is still generated by the
compiler here
and then comes the Crux of this the
Pinnacle of this design I want to have
static Factory functions for a row which
is
calculating correct values for all those
four variables
then for the
column
then for the diagonal and anti-diagonal
to agree and complicated ones where you
have plus minus one bug opportunity
so we have four static Factory functions
as you can see you can add anything you
like into a record it is a class like
any other you can add your own methods
you can add methods that are calculating
something that are changing or not
changing by creating uh a new record
object
it is just a regular class into which
compiler will inject some 20 30 lines of
code for you
and so look at this
do you remember the Prototype look
disgusting
nice
that's the difference so you will use
all those
syntactic elements functional syntactic
elements to
prove that you're that your ideas work
but after that before you commit and
head for the bar while your code is
traveling towards production you'll
probably want to make sure that your
classes are statically typed in the
verifiable you will introduce proper
domain models for for all those tiny
elements that were missing
okay
this still works
there should be no compile time error
and I cannot use a mouse on this
class no
okay no compile time error
multi-level deconstruction works very
well even with your record
classes
but now
maybe I wanted to use proper domain
models here to avoid confusion in the UI
again everything has assumed a strong
name that is Again verifiable by the
compiler so you have
an opportunity to move your design in
small steps and to improve it
but still all the time since the very
beginning this is the same design I
changed very little in the way it it
operates
all right
what about this
uh yes playable cells are in the board
playable cells are tuples
my implicit operator is
has jumped in
and this is the moment when I start
fearing for my safety because I'm not
sure that I expected that to happen so
this is probably the moment when you
will go to this prototype and tell all
right thank you very much and at least
comment it out or delete it
yes
but
in line what
oh
I don't know and I'm not sure that I
would like to have it I don't know I
mean that that means that um one thing
is applied in in multiple places
yes but uh I mean I would prefer uh an
extension method or an explicit operator
in place of uh that so that all those
places that need it uh would refer to
that single implementation rather than
copy its body over there
if you know what I mean
okay so now I have to
fix this and
okay
now
we come to a more advanced
all right I will I will return this
because I still haven't
removed these prototyping elements from
here so and still need it but in five
minutes time we should remove this
definitely okay
now this is functional programmer in me
showing all that I
know on this piece of code what are the
playable cells
now you start thinking about Expressions
how do we calculate
playable cells
if there are any winning lines then
there are no playable cells empty
otherwise
take the full board nine cell elements
this will be an innumerable of cell
I don't have it yet but I see the design
I will put them here
so this is just an ugly expression
that returns nine cell objects with
unique coordinates
if you never saw functional c-sharp
I don't know what to tell you how to
make it easy for you but anyway
if you take an innumerable of cell
representing the entire board then just
say accept moves
these are the cells that were never
played and the user should be able to
click them I don't have the move
sequence yet but listen
why will this work
because of equality testing operators
that were implemented for me
that's the point and I'm using records
all the time because all those dislarge
classes those hundreds of these large
classes in my code they're all testable
for equality and I can use them in
collections as keys to dictionaries in
here sets I can I can check whether
there are duplicates anything I need
When developing a complex domain model I
can do because equality testing becomes
a native feature of my objects
and I can write one line of code like
this and it will do a complicated
operation then
what are these moves
if you are developing an immutable model
then you will probably need immutable
collections
how many of you have been working with
immutable collections
oh that's better
okay
immutable collections come with a cost
and added cost they have logarithmic uh
added logarithmic time on everything
where common collections have uh unit
time
so it is and logarithm and time to add
an element to a list not all fan
so these collections have a cost
so you will avoid creating huge
immutable objects like thousands of
items inside but if you have nine items
inside performance penalty will be
negligible
but design
uh effects will be
great I will have an immutable domain
model all the way through
so when you
design an immutable class functional
style which includes a collection it
will
this will become your muscle memory then
create a private Constructor which
receives an immutable collection of all
the content then initialize it to an
empty immutable collection the first
time and whenever you want okay just
repeat that whenever you want to add to
that collection create a new
that will be this helper method below
use the collection to add con oh no no
this is something totally dispute forget
this is the line I want I was talking to
you
I was telling uh create
new collection by adding an element to
it immutable collections return a new
collection with one element added and
the old reference
remains intact nothing changes in depth
and then create a new instance of your
object with the new collection inside of
it
and this expression which I'm
constructing here do you know what it's
doing
if I wanted to play on this cell that
cell might be occupied so what I'm doing
or better yet functional programming
tiny uh functional programming in me
is searching through all the playable
cells which are equal to this one and
there can be only one such uh
cell converting that one into a new
board otherwise rejecting the move by
doing nothing
this is homework for you for those of
you who never saw functional expressions
and just return the first one of these
it's either a played board or the same
board as this one so it either accepted
or rejecting the rejected the move you
can even choose to throw exceptions from
from this operator but there is no
default eventually operator that accepts
a Lambda yet
so you cannot just throw an exception
here okay this is Advanced functional
programming in c sharp if you like
start thinking about it
we only need to implement home and the
way it moves and the game will work
this
picks all moves that have an even
offset those are the moves made by the
Home player
but
this is ugly This is complicated this is
error prone and I will have to duplicate
it here with only a single this zero
switch to one
if you already have a functional model
which is based on uh
sequences equal terrible objects
things like that you can start designing
your own link extensions like that
default event that receives a Lambda a
lazy default if empty which does not
exist in.net yet
how do you do that and why do you do
that
one is to move all the ugly code under
the rack so you just create an extension
method put it somewhere else and put all
the ugly code in there and just hide it
behind a nice name
that is one reason
the other reason is that if you placed
this code somewhere else then you start
asking why am I using link to implement
this when it is not efficient enough
link is semi nicely looking it is
I don't know if you if I had names if I
had methods for these operations this
expression would really look nice
it would be a select uh this method
where that
that method that returns Boolean select
disk
conversion you know and it would be a
really nice expression a chain of of
Link operators with all the alarm does
it is ugly and it is not really
efficient
so this is better
and this is procedural
take the enumerator if parity is greater
than zero which is one more skip the
first element then
skip twice per iteration job done and
this is the most efficient way to do
that
however
this method
is accepting
parity so I can say
Prosperity 1000 here
which is not valid so what you do
in a
design which is safe from Bugs
you would create a private extension
method which is very efficient
and exposed to static public
methods that are giving a name to those
parameters like where even offset where
odd offset and you would fix the
parameter
and this is good
now you go
back to this code and implement it this
way
and what do you say now
all that ugliness has been moved away
turned into a better implementation and
hidden away from everyone so that nobody
can make a mistake
winning lines
Advanced plus level
look at this
I could
use a line to expose
some helper method which tells me
lines formed by these cells
and whenever
cells form a line of free
that is the winning line all right so I
need home players winning lines away
players winning lines
this is the expression that calculates
that so
another ugly
expression in the line which is doing a
very complicated
deliberation by grouping lines
which are Equitable so they they can be
grouped by themselves and every cell
should tell us two which lies it belongs
can you follow this does anybody can
follow this
Maybe
but if you started thinking this way
if you start thinking like my entire
domain model splits into
querying and commanding to it so forget
commands querying is a bunch of
expressions
there are no Loops there are no nothing
just an expression what is the formula
for what this function says it will
return
use expression body syntax all the way
through never see
acrylic braces I'm not sure that there
are any curly braces in this code except
in that extension method and over there
maybe in the in the UI in the domain
model it's all arrows
expression body syntax so the idea is to
ask every single cell to which lines it
belongs then to group those lines and
count all the groups that have free
elements those are the winning lines
you see that is the expression
for winning lines
and all I need
is the cell this is the cell class to
tell me that it belongs to this row to
this column maybe to this diagonal and
maybe to this anti-diagonal so it
returns two three or four elements
and that expression over there once I
add a link
will compile and work fine
I will save this
these are the elements
I think that everything is in place
but I cannot use this mouse on this
glass
so
where are you
I can play
I have already made a mistake the fork
attack
and while I'm winning
the the last element which I promised to
you what can be done with this immutable
domain model that is very hard to be
implemented if Board model were mutable
yes
undo very good idea and much simpler
than my idea
yes undo you would just show the
previous version of the board and you're
done
and there is there is the whole bunch of
algorithms that are
based on that same ability for example
if I wanted to play against the computer
I would have to search for States now
every state is a single board object
you see with
mutable board if any of you ever
implemented a board game with a mutable
domain model I did that on a much more
complicated board game than this and it
was yeah
with this it is two lines of code
literally
so I hope you enjoyed this I have won
the game
if you have any questions you can ask
them now
yes
there is the with expression where where
you say with this object open curly
braces and just set that one property
that will construct a new object with
the modified that single value and
everything else just copied that's
with records yes you can Implement that
on your own within its syntax and
there is a lot of complicate complexity
in that and doing that manually but it
works out of the box with records
yes
my experience is that it that it is
probably best to start small you can
always create one small class that is
functional that is immutable that
separates commands from queries and
works in this way it will not make any
troubles to all other classes in the
domain and then you build from that and
keep a building
you will see that there are more and
more things that you can do that work
very hard without that for example
multi-threading
task parallelism this is Task parallel
ready with no no zero lines of code to
use it in in task parallelism if I made
this not only mutable but if I use a
mutable list inside it does not
guarantee that every single bit will
remain intact even if nobody is changing
it it does not it explicitly says that
they don't guarantee it
if I use it in task parallel expression
would it work will it explode later I
don't know
with if I had a bunch of classes that
were designed in this way months ago I
would just say yes everything is safe I
don't have to think
yes
yes that is a good question what about
memory we are using many small objects
many many many small objects
that is not a problem for garbage
collected languages because garbage
collection is very efficient in that
mode if it has many small objects it do
know how it works it has a pointer to to
the free location and it adds new
objects on at the end when the garbage
collection happens none of these will be
visited because there are no references
to them they are all forgotten except a
couple of those that are still alive
those that are alive will be copied to
the beginning
compacted and everything else
remains just to move the pointer that is
a single assignment operation so all the
other objects all the other short living
objects are just skipped the cost is
zero to garbage collect them
all right if you have anything else I
will be around uh
we can talk
I would also like to hear your your
experience thank you for coming and
enjoy the rest of the conference